un nouvel affichage va arriver près des
aires de jeux d'ici quelques jours il ne
sera plus possible de fumer près désert
pour enfants fontenay-le-fleury
s'associe avec la ligue contre le cancer
pour mettre en place des espaces sans
tabac c'était dans le cadre du plan
santé de la ville et puis c'était aussi
puisque tous ces endroits des espaces
publics où on va installer des panneaux
n'était pas protégée en fait
par la loi contre le tabac donc
on s'est dit que déjà pour éviter que
les jeunes s'initier au tabac protéger
l'environnement des mégots de cigarettes
et puis réduire le tabagisme passif de
la prévention avant la mise en place de
sanctions le non respect de ces espaces
entraînera une amende de 38 euros quinze
lieux seront concernés dont les huit
établissements scolaires de la commune
je pense que c'est une bonne chose déjà
deux d'éloigner les enfants
tout ce qui peut être
fumé de cigarette les odeurs les
habitudes aussi c'est jamais évident
parce qu'il ya des habitudes ont été
prises et donc c'est faire changer les
habitudes c'est faire changer ce que les
adultes peuvent nous proposer déjà 29
ans j'ai toujours eu des gens qu'on fume
et je ne suis pas morte pour autant moi
je pars du principe que si on a fumé en
fumure à moi j'étais grosse fumeuse à
l'époque parce qu'effectivement j'ai pas
eu de ma mère n'a jamais fumé j'ai fait
comme les autres à l'école ou au collège
plus exactement j'ai commencé j'avais 12
ans d'autres lieux pourrait devenir des
espaces sans tabac sur la commune comme
les gymnases et le collège 30% de
l'ensemble des cancers dépendent du
tabac